and Comics Golden Age Dr fee committed  at least two genocides and more fun  comics issue 61 Dr Fate is flying  through space when he sees a strange  nebula with a flaming Globe at its core  hanging around Earth somehow this breaks  Earth's orbit around the sun almost  freezing the planet before Doctor Fate  destroys the nebula with an atom  shatterer he found on distant Uranus but  then he finds a whole Fleet of nebulae  coming for the Earth and traces them to  what he calls a pirate Planet so Dr  Fates throws the whole planet into the  Sun and kills everybody on it you'd  think one genocide is already too many  but Dr Fate goes for another and more  fun issue 65. the Fishman of Niall are  man who look kind of like reverse  mermaids rise out of the sea to conquer  the Earth fate hunts down their  underwater city and blows it to  Smithereens the narration assures  readers that its Fallen ruins shelter no  single threat of life except official to